ils sont quarante artistes sculpteurs
photographes au peintre leurs styles
diffèrent leur notoriété aussi mais tous
se sont prêtés à la même contrainte
travailler sur des formats carrés
deuxième règle librement consenti
reverser une partie du produit de la
vente de leurs oeuvres à une association
humanitaire - j'ai eu le plaisir de
travailler de faire une peinture que
j'aime d'avoir un métier que j'aime et
si on peut redonner du plaisir aux
autres
en faisant cette démarche pour tu es
libre max je trouve que c'est magnifique
et le partage se fait partie de la vie
et se partagent la moi j'y crois
cette année les artistes ont décidé de
soutenir l'action de thé libre max une
association qui milite et agit pour
l'autonomie des personnes handicapées
mentales
le projet phare de l'association c'est
construire une maison domotique pour des
jeunes devenus adultes en situation de
handicap mental c'est à dire que ce sera
leur maison ce sera leur chez eux pour
plus tard il y aura bien sûr des
éducateurs mais ils vivront dans cette
maison 365 jours par an
l'exposition-vente se tient au dos même
de la trésorerie à
saint-pryvé-saint-mesmin près d'orléans
jusqu'à dimanche prochain
[Musique]